you know I don't blame Elijah Wood at
all for being scared out of his mind in
this movie because if I had John
Cusack's voice in my ear at all times
whispering things to me I'd be pretty
terrified too grand piano stars Elijah
Wood and John Cusack
now Elijah Wood in this movie is a
concert pianist and he's been out of the
scene for five years because he very
famously choked at a huge concert that
really ruined his career he's been made
fun of it for a long time and he's
finally coming back to perform his first
concert in five years and he's gonna be
doing it as a tribute to the man who
mentored him because he has recently
passed away as he's beginning his
concert he's looking at his piece of
music in front of him and he sees a note
on it that says if you play one wrong
note you will die eventually he gets the
ear piece in his ear during intermission
and John Cusack is on the other end of
the line saying that if he plays one
wrong note he's going to snipe him from
up in the halls and this starts a very
tense almost Hitchcockian thriller in
which Elijah Wood has to play the
perfect concert while playing the one
piece of music that he effed up on
originally five years ago now I won't
give away the reason for why John
Cusack's character is doing this because
that ruins a lot of the fun of the movie
because I actually had a really good
time with grand piano this is a small
movie and I wasn't planning on seeing it
until I heard some really good things
about it I heard it was really well
directed and that is absolutely true
this movie is directed fantastically the
camera hardly ever stops moving in this
film there's lots of moving shots long
takes you get a lot of great shots of
Elijah Wood playing these pieces and you
can see that he really knows how to play
the piano he's not using a hand double
or anything this guy knows what he's
doing and it was really cool to see
Elijah Wood in a really good performance
because he is extremely frightened
throughout the entire majority of this
movie and he pulls off all of the
tenseness that is needed and this movie
really feels almost like it could come
out in the 60s where they were making a
lot of really great suspense thrillers
that were based on these very simple
plots and for the majority of this movie
John Cusack has a voice in Elijah woods
ear but he does a very good job with the
work that he's provided I really really
like the way this movie looks it has a
fantastic editing style and overall it's
an extremely well crafted movie that
actually made me very very
invested in this guy's play the biggest
flaw of this movie is and it takes a lot
of liberties with the way classical
concert generally go now I'm not gonna
be like the guy who says I know
everything about classical concerts
because I watch movies because I don't I
have been to a lot of classical concerts
though because someone that I know is a
very good cellist and he does a lot of
stuff and I've seen a lot of his work
and so I know the movie takes a lot of
liberties with the way concerts are
actually held there's a lot of things
that are obviously done for story points
to enhance the film that wouldn't
normally take place and a lot of people
are going to complain about that if you
are a concert person who knows a lot
about this kind of stuff but I recognize
this is a film and they're trying to
make a film and although there are
certain liberties taken with the way
these concerts are held it's such a well
made movie with really good performances
and an interesting plot hook that I was
willing to overlook them the music in
the movie is fantastic the director of
this film is also a composer so he knows
a lot about music and he's able to make
a lot of these scenes seem realistic in
the way the concert is portrayed now as
I said there are some liberties taken
with the actual like sequence of events
of a concert but the way these guys
perform this music and the way it sounds
is excellent and as I said Elijah Wood
is extremely good on the piano and he
really sells all those scenes very well
the suspense felt real the tension was
palpable I was into the moment
I enjoyed the characters in this movie
the finale is kind of cliched but the
way that it all rolls into one I thought
was really interesting and made for a
good payoff and I found the film
rewarding despite some of its flaws and
so I enjoyed watching grand piano and
I'm gonna give it a B guys this movie is
available right now on video on demand
it's in a few theaters but I would check
it out if you are a fan of suspense
films or that tense style that Alfred
Hitchcock made so famous guys thanks so
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stammen
eyes
[Music]
so guys a lot of people have been asking
me about the audible promotion that I'm
running these guys really like my videos
they like what I'm doing inaudible is a
website that allows you to download any
book that you want that's on audio and
you can listen to it on your mp3 player
or your tablet or your computer wherever
you want to and through me they're
allowing me to give you guys a free book
if you want it you can download it at
audible.com slash Chris that's
audible.com slash Chris a lot of people
have been asking me what the exact URL
is it's in the video description below
it's a free gift from me to you through
audible and if you would like to
download a free book that is your choice
and you can have it for free thanks so
much guys and have a good day